o o
oh
vous allez chanter ce soir à bordeaux et
que mettrez vous à votre programme parti
de poutine y dédier tout à puccini ou
chanter les airs de jeanne expliqué de
l'est ou du tour en dot manon manon
lescaut et visiteurs de toscane pour la
première partie
jeu lorsque dans des salons menace un
final de salomé pour la deuxième partie
solo mais que je crois vous allez
chanter en entier bientôt oui on va la
faire à parier avec le nabaztag mois de
mai prochain quel personnage que vous
préférez et à trois personnages que je
préfère que je chanterai souvent ce sont
ravis atteint normand et salomé qu'est
le plus difficile des trois je pense que
tous les droits sont difficiles
d'édifices erreur que jamais chanté
c'est le pirate de vélines et était doué
pour ça qu'on ne chante pas moi non plus
celui que vous préférez
et c'est sur ça l'aurait salon même si
j'aime beaucoup ce halo mais j'aime
beaucoup ce talent devant c'est la
première fois donc que vous venez à
bordeaux
vous connaissiez cette ville ou bien non
je veux une emprise et là c'est vraiment
la première fois qu'on vient ici et
c'est la première fois que je suis dans
les théâtres dedans on montre la salle a
montré un peu tout le succès fantastique
les cellules acoustique
non pas encore mais je des bonnes
nouvelles
tout le monde dit que je te vont alors
que candice accola romain il marche
comme ça ça veut dire que c'est vrai et
j'espère le constater ce soir et en même
temps vraiment ici on a l'impression
d'être dans une vrai théâtre